les débats reprennent dans une heure à
l'assemblée nationale sur le projet doit
donc lié au passage vaccinale une séance
suspendue pour la deuxième fois en deux
jours hier soir au palais bourbon en
cause les propos donc d' emmanuel macron
dans le parisien le président qui je
cite a très envie d'en garder jusqu'au
bout les non vaccinés
moi je ne suis pas pour emmerder les
français je passe toute la journée
contre l'administration quand lé bloc
est bien là les non vaccinés j'ai très
envie de les emmerder et donc on va
continuer de le faire jusqu'au bout
c'est ça la stratégie je ne vais pas les
mettre en prison je ne vais pas les
vaccinés de force et donc il faut leur
dire à partir du 15 janvier vous ne
pourrez plus aller au resto vous ne
pourrez plus prendre un canon vous ne
pourrez plus aller boire un café vous ne
pourrez plus aller au théâtre vous ne
pourrez plus aller au ciné une sortie
polémique du chef de l'état qui fait
réagir l'opposition retrouve justement
tout de suite admis de khalifa à
l'assemblée nationale où les débats vont
reprendre à 15 heures
david troisième jour de débat à quoi
peut-on s'attendre
cet après midi
une nouvelle mais de perdus pour
l'exécutif qui souhaitait voir ce texte
de voix passé a rapidement ses
déclarations d' emmanuel macron qu'on
bouleversé ces débats qui s'enlise
depuis deux jours au sein du palais
bourbon des débats qui sont censés
reprendre à 15 heures mais dans quelles
conditions c'est la grande question à
l'opposition politique s'est indigné
jean luc mélenchon décrit un aveu
sidérant et invite le premier ministre à
venir expliquer la stratégie
d'emmerdements des français devant
l'assemblée nationale valérie pécresse
candidate des républicains estiment que
ce n'est pas au président de trier les
bons et les mauvais français marine le
pen la présidente du rassemblement
national pointe du doigt la vulgarité à
du président qui prouve à qui ne s'est
jamais considéré comme le président de
tous les français pour en parler je suis
avec bruno bonnell député de la
république en marche bonjour monsieur
bonnel merci de répondre à nos questions
alors que répondez vous à ces réactions
de l'opposition politique ben justement
ce sont des réactions de l'opposition
politique faire des professionnels la
politique d'ailleurs qui ne se gênent
pas eu quand il faut nous traiter de
godillots ou de larbin ou que sais-je
encore des mots ça ici l'insultant
politique tuer ça fait longtemps que
toute l'assemblée nationale
je serais morte donc arrêtons avec ces
guignolade la réalité c'est que moi chez
mon boulanger dans la rue quand je fais
la queue pour mes enfants qui ont besoin
d'autotest à la pharmacie je me dis mais
mais c'est vrai que si on était tous
vaccinés ça vous change la vie et donc
quand le président parle comme on parle
dans la rue comment on nous dit oui
notre vie est un petit peu emmerdé entre
guillemets par ces restrictions ont dit
ouh là là il est vulgaire puis quand il
parle avec des mots tic depuis cinq
lettres on dit oulala il est littéraire
il est auteur hors sol je crois qu'il a
descendu il est descendu dans l'arène il
a écouté les français il a dit ce n'est
pas une minorité de 8 % de gens qui sont
non vaccinés de dicter l'avenir la vie
sociale de 92 % des gens qu'ils le sont
donc à un moment donné on siffle un peu
la fin de la récré et on dit si vous
voulez continuer à être non vaccinés
nous respectons ce choix nous le
respectons vous êtes des citoyens comme
les autres et si vous ne voulez pas
si vous voulez pas être vaccinés et bien
vous avez un problème c'est que vous
n'avez pas accès aux mêmes droits que
les autres à savoir une citoyenneté vous
êtes un citoyen mais votre droit de
citoyenneté un peu différent pourquoi
parce que si vous perturber il
n'acceptait pas le jeu social c'est
vous-même qui décidez vous exclure de
cette sphère donc arrêtons avec les
idées de dictature quand je vais en en
afrique subsaharienne je suis vacciné de
la fièvre jaune sinon je n'entre pas je
n'entre pas dans le pays ici on dit bah
oui mais si vous n'êtes pas vacciné
ensemble de lieux qui vous seront reçus
je précise au passage que quand vous
parlez avec les soignants qui vous
racontent que la totalité ou la grande
grande majorité des gens qui sont
réanimation sont des gens qui sont non
vaccinés ils y passent des nuits il ya
là les soigner à les soulager et ça sera
toujours le cas parce que la france
traitera indifféremment tous les
français en terme de santé bien si gens
vous disent mais s'il avait été vacciné
il ne serait pas là et si en tant que
père de famille vous arrivé un soir avec
un enfant qui a quelque chose qui
nécessite l'occupation d'un lit dans un
hôpital et qu'on vous explique ben non
pas de chance tous les lits sont occupés
par les vacciner je pense que la glide
et d'emmerdés c'est un petit mot par
rapport à plein de mots vous auriez à
prononcer à ce moment là c'était cette
interview donnée au parisien ce que ce
n'est pas le lancement officieux de sa
campagne présidentielle et si si oui à
quand la halle annonce officielle alors
ça c'est au président de décider quand
il se présenterait nous bien évidemment
nous soutenons toute idée de candidature
il dit dans cette interview qu'il en a
envie et qu'il a un projet donc on va on
va on va regarder ce que ça veut dire
tout cas on va le soutenir ce quant à la
majorité présidentielle
mais encore une fois il dit quelque
chose de très raisonnable il dit au
milieu d'une crise sanitaire je suis
président je suis à la gouverne de ce
pays je n'ai pas allez commencer à faire
des meetings électoraux où allait
commencer à avoir un programme électoral
d'élaborer pour le futur
donc encore une fois il fait la chose la
plus importante pour un chef il gère les
priorités sa priorité aujourd'hui c'est
la santé des français est notre priorité
c'est le pack vaccinale et plus les
oppositions continueront à jouer aux
guignols dans l'assemblée nationale avec
des prétextes pour délayer le temps de
le mettre en place et bien plus on prend
là on mettra des français à risque et on
gérera mal ses priorités justement ces
débats parlementaires sur
parce vaccinale est ce que ce n'est pas
le reflet de l'ambiance politique
générale à moins de 100 jours de
l'élection présidentielle à savoir tous
contre la république en marche et tous
contre la politique des manuels ma peau
évidemment une campagne électorale c'est
contre le pouvoir en place et je
comprends que vu la faiblesse des idées
des oppositions ils n'ont rien d'autre à
faire que des des grands gestes et et à
vociférer dans l'hémicycle ceci dit moi
je les invite surtout à proposer des
vraies solutions aux problèmes qu'ils
évoquent moi je veux bien des vraies
solutions alternatives sur la
vaccination et quand j'entends qu'il
faut juste contenté de mettre deux
filtres de co2 dans chaque école vous
irez miraculeusement de régler la crise
je trouve que c'est pas tout à fait à la
hauteur des enjeux nous savons que le
vaccin est la solution quand j'entends
aussi l'incohérence des discours nous
sommes pour la vaccination mais nous ne
sommes pas pour le pass vaccinale donc
ça veut dire que pour vos enfants à qui
vous mettez 11 vaccin pour qu'ils
aillent à l'école alors on est pour la
vaccination mais le carnet de santé le
carnet médical on est contre non mais
attendez le pass vaccinale c'est ni plus
ni moins qu'un carnet de vaccination et
rien de plus oui il faut le présenter
aujourd'hui si nous étions tous vaccinés
eh bien nous aurons nous pourrions
reprendre une vie normale et la voir
dans la poche vous savez moi j'ai 63 ans
je crois que j'ai présentée deux fois
dans ma vie mon carnet de vaccination
donc ne pas activer à c'est un peu
pareil l'avoir sur soi ça serait juste
une formalité on aurait pu le présenter
si nous étions tous accidents dernière
qu'il souhaite que ce camouflet sur le
pass vaccinale ce n'est pas un vilain
coup pour la future campagne
présidentielle d'emmanuel mâcon moi
j'aime bien le mot camouflet
comme si on avait reçu vraiment un coup
savez qui met ko moi je dirais que c'est
plutôt une victoire à la pyrrhus d'une
opposition savez une victoire à la
pyrrhus c'est ce fameux chef grecque qui
croyait avoir gagné une bataille mais il
a vite perdu la moitié de ses troupes
l'opposition continue à faire croire que
l'assemblée nationale est un lieu
simplement pour se montrer et faire des
grands gestes doré réfléchir à ce que
leurs électeurs en penses dans la
responsabilité qui prennent à faire
cette espèce de comme l'a dit gabriela
talent eu d'amical de l'irresponsabilité
moi j'ai rajouté et du cynisme merci
beaucoup à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes la députée de la république
est en marche et je rappelle également
qu'il reste 450 amendements à examiner
durant à ces débats qui rouvriront à 15
heures concernant le projet de loi sur
le passé vaccinale merci david khalifa
pour toutes ces précisions et cette
interview de bruno bonnell à l'assemblée
nationale merci également à battice
gosselin qui vous accompagnent derrière
la caméra